President Trump will visit Las Vegas
tomorrow to meet with victims and their
families this morning he called the
gunman a sick man the president spoke
before taking off for Puerto Rico he
will meet with Hurricane Maria victims
and first responders today David beg
know is in San Juan David good morning
good morning the president is expected
to highlight the work that is being done
by federal relief workers here on the
ground after that work was criticized as
being too slow and the criticism came
from local leaders and people who so
desperately waited up to ten days to get
food water they could drink ninety five
percent of this island is still without
power and still today people are asking
for food and water
begging for it but there are signs of
progress 12,000 federal aid workers are
here hospitals and airports are coming
back online
70% of gas stations are back up and
running and the gas lines have gone from
18-hour Waits
to less than an hour in the capital of
San Juan they've got 700,000 pounds of
supplies that they're distributing but
when you get out into the rural areas of
the island there are people who are
tapping into streams to get drinking
water you know Jeff the mayor of San
Juan was blistering in her criticism of
the federal government and she was
subsequently attacked by the president
for being a poor leader the White House
confirms the president and the mayor
will meet later today David thank you